wir sehen am 21 august um etwa sechs uhr
45 also normalerweise in der zeit wo man
beginnt sich an den dienst zu erinnern
alarmiert worden
keine zusätzlichen maßnahmen waren
erforderlich die der marsch in die
kaserne etwa zehn minuten viertelstunde
ist bevorstand ich habe getroffen
während des marsches in die kaserne dem
kompaniekommandanten der nt kompanie das
war damals der oberleutnant oder leuten
anteile und trinke sagt wir sind diesmal
alarmiert worden ohne dass wir vorher
irgendeine information bekommen haben
mag es hat ich glaube ich dass in der in
die nachrichten sind gekommen dass die
die russen grässlich geburt isetta oder
die russen
dass die russen in prag einmarschiert
sind und in der tschechoslowakei
besetzen etwa 344 oder haben wir den
applaus bekommen in den verfügungsrahmen
zu marschieren die erste und die zweite
kompanie
wir sind im land marsch gefahren nach
ein stärke sind circa 90 kilometer
gewesen darum 60 radio das leicht mit
einem dunk beschäftigt wir sind mit 16
panzer gefahren einer war gerade in der
in der werkstätte
was kommt weiß
nicht mehr und er ist uns aber in den
einsatzraum in den verfügungsrahmen nach
geführt wurden mit dem tieflader und wir
sind in den verfügungsrahmen einstieg in
gerthe weit gefahren
wir sind mit der mit dem bataillon
kommando und der zweiten kompanie
panzergrenadierbataillon 9 des damals in
weitere gewesen ist und aus in den raum
plötzlich kommando und wir sind im geld
hinein gefahren und ungemütlich
niedergelassen der verfügungsrahmen wir
haben keinen pc kopka wasser gehabt zum
waschen wir haben im nächsten tag ist
oder übernächsten tag ist ein großraum
zelt aufgebaut worden
dort haben wir geschlafen wir haben
keine monika möglichkeit kommt für die
kanzlei und für so viel schriftverkehr
und so weiter haben wir nicht gehabt ich
im nächsten tag ist die munition die
kompanien gekommen und da haben wird in
der rest der munition aufgenommen würden
wir sind vollauf munitioniert gewesen
mit dem panzer die die kleine munition
die mg munition die höhe ist im kino
nation haben wir schon in st pölten
gelagert gehabt ich war überhaupt kein
problem diese munition in den wald
hinein zu bekommen
am sonntag ist hingehen vielleicht schon
unsere frauen hinauf gekommen die die
haben die soldaten schon ausgang
bekommen wir sind am samstag schon mit
den soldaten baden gefahren baden und da
anführungsstrichen mit der compagnie in
den k
dass man uns gewaschen haben
und wir haben wir keine möglichkeit
gehabt in geroda war eine eine gleiche
quelle rede sein